vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Marta Moya Marta Buenos días para
ustedes Hola Ángela Buenos días y vamos
a empezar hoy hablando de Estados Unidos
ayer se consumó lo que venía gestándose
desde hace días y es el anuncio del
gobernador de la Florida ron de santis
de que se une a la carrera por la
presidencia por el lado republicano un
evento que fue todo menos ortodoxo en
sus propias palabras y que hoy está en
todos los medios y también en todas las
redes sociales Marta si le parece vamos
a empezar por político sí Ángela un
evento de verdad que no escapó a la
polémica y a las risas por todo lo
fallido que fue empezamos con político
que titula el lanzamiento de campaña de
deshantes estuvo empañado por horrendas
fallas tecnológicas el día anterior ya
se había anunciado que él hasta ahora
gobernador de Florida y también ya
precandidato republicano a la
presidencia en 2024 iba a presentar su
candidatura con el ceo de Twitter elon
musk a través de esta aplicación pero
ayer Twitter se rompió estaba todo
organizado para hacer un spaces que es
una suerte de reunión virtual solo a
través de audio en Twitter pero las
fallas fueron constantes mientras miles
de personas esperaban a que el candidato
anunciara esa valga la redundancia
candidatura entre 200.000 y 300.000
personas Al inicio se llegaron a
conectar más de 600.000 rondas antes
solo pudo empezar a hablar pasados 30
minutos desde que se anunciara que Pues
iba a empezar el evento político dice el
espectáculo representó una gran
vergüenza tanto para de santis como para
Mask al primero por atormentar su acto
mientras se embarca en un intento por
ganar la nominación del partido
republicano y al segundo mientras
intenta posicionarse como un hacedor
político en el panorama de los nuevos
medios por supuesto este evento como
decimos no estuvo exento de polémica y
también político destaca que la Fox news
que tenía después de todo en Twitter una
entrevista concertada con ron de santis
y una cadena amiga para el candidato
republicano se rieron un poco de lo
ocurrido con elon musk en Twitter quizá
también un poco con retanca de que no
les hubieran elegido a ellos para que
rondes antis presentara su candidatura y
prometieron a ron de santis que su
conexión no se iba a caer durante la
entrevista ron de sandis asumiendo un
poquito El golpe dijo que ahora una vez
presentaran su campaña de donaciones en
internet esperaban también romper esa
parte de Internet pues mire eso ha dado
mucho para hablar y por eso vamos a
seguir haciendo más repasos que dice
box.com pues Ángela box.com dice por
decirlo suavemente Y esto es textual fue
un desastre fue el caos y la anarquía el
audio entraba y salía la aplicación
expulsaba constantemente a los usuarios
que esperaban escuchar al gobernador de
Florida y durante la primera media hora
cartucho comentarios cruzados entre elon
musk y David zacks el multimillonario
que intentaban pues
solucionar o concretar un poco lo que
estaba pasando no dice vox dotcom es
difícil recordar un anuncio de campaña
más chapucero en los últimos años pero
todavía rondesandis dice este mismo
artículo tiene margen de maniobra Aunque
la primera imagen que tiene los
estadounidenses de este anuncio de
campaña pues sea la de un tipo que
arruinó su propio lanzamiento a la casa
blanca bueno Habría que ver porque de
todas maneras está este dicho de que no
hay buen animal la publicidad solo
publicidad no Qué diseño New York Times
pues Ángela Times destaca Pues un poco
los problemas que ha venido presentando
Twitter desde que elon musk asumió pues
esta red social y se hizo dueño de la
misma no dice el New York Times que los
problemas han sido constantes que por
ejemplo en el mes de febrero la
aplicación se llegó a caer cuatro veces
que es el doble de lo que se cayó en
todo 2022 además que las
infraestructuras pues son muy precarias
desde que elon musk se hizo dueño de
Twitter que ha habido despidos masivos
que se cargó a los supervisores de los
servidores y del almacenamiento en la
nube Y que además ha tomado decisiones
muy arbitrarias como pues aceptar las
peticiones de censura de parte de
gobiernos autoritarios o Pues todo el
tema del Tic azul de las cuentas
verificadas no eso dice el New York
Times un fiasco En conclusión por
supuesto estas fallas técnicas no
estuvieron exentas Marta de memes y de
comentarios en redes también por parte
de sus principales contendores Pues si
Ángela Twitter se cayó para la
presentación de santis pero no se cayó
para los memes y sus principales rivales
de campaña tanto Joe biden como Donald
Trump aprovecharon la ocasión para pues
hacer un poco de política y también
reírse un poco del candidato ron de
santis Vamos a repasar tres fragmentos
que utilizaron tanto la campaña de biden
como la de Donald Trump Para reírse de
todo lo sucedido escuchemos
[Música]
[Aplausos]
solo me puedo imaginar la rabieta de
rondes antes sí seguro que no fue poca
vamos a cambiar de tema rápidamente no
podemos dejar esto fuera y es el
fallecimiento de la cantante Tina Turner
que ha elevado todo tipo de reacciones y
de homenajes alrededor del mundo y usted
tiene algunos en la prensa sí Ángela
hemos destacado cinco portadas de la
prensa internacional empezamos con el
Wall Street journal titula Tina Turner
una leyenda musical en dos actos la
cantante se sobrepuso a un tortuoso y
abusivo primer matrimonio y alcanzó la
cima y el estrellato musical y esta
murió el miércoles en su residencia en
Suiza la segunda portada que destacamos
es la del Washington post que titula por
siempre La Reina del rock and roll la
saga personal y de lucha y el
resurgimiento siguen Y seguirán siendo
fuente de inspiración en Liberación en
Francia una imagen icónica Tina Turner
es la mejor En referencia a su gran
éxito ellos siempre debes la de
Sao Paulo en Brasil titula muere Tina
Turner a los 83 años una diva que
se lanzó al estrellato en los años 80 y
cuya muerte pues es cuyos las causas de
la muerte no fueron anunciados ayer y
hemos destacado también la portada del
periódico de España que titulaba muere
tina de Best un poco como Liberación
destaca que pues fue homenajeada en todo
el mundo tanto por parte de la industria
musical como por fuera hermosísima la
portada de liberación gracias a usted
Marta y hoy nos dedicaremos a escuchar a
Tina Turner Así es Ángela